pour devenir espion il faut effacer son
ancienne vie alors comment disparaître
d'Internet supprimer ses comptes ne
suffit pas à chaque fois qu'on a posté
une photo il plaudé un CV donner son nom
c'est gravé à jamais sur les disques
durs d'un serveur quelque part et
uploader en boucle internet n'oubliez
rien c'est comme ça qu'on a retrouvé le
créateur de cyclone l'Amazone de la
drogue à cause d'un vieux poste sur un
forum obscur il faisait pas attention à
l'époque aujourd'hui c'est prison à vie
depuis 2014 on a le droit l'oubli
numérique mais c'est long et ça ne
marche pas toujours alors la meilleure
méthode c'est de noyer l'information
faites des dizaines de copies de
vous-même avec des profils différents
qu'on sache pas si vous êtes chirurgien
en France ou professeur de mathématiques
aux Caraïbes vous trouvez ça long
compliqué oui le mieux c'est de pas en
arriver là pour ça informez-vous dès
maintenant grâce au site numérique
etic.fr par la MAIF c'est plein de bons
conseils pour protéger votre vie
numérique
utile car